on dit que ma mère était la plus
extraordinaire de toutes les cavalières
reste toujours libre mikari daf recul et
même si elle nous a quittés quand
j'étais l'aider
[Musique]
à certains moments je reçois encore sa
présence
[Musique]
c
oh
[Musique]
bienvenue à meerab héros tente quand tu
as déjà vu le spectacle de maman ou
alors que oui ta mère était une légende
au lard c'est fou ce que tu ressens
battent à mort
qui doit être c'est qu'ils prescott
j'adore ton robe et des chaussures puis
avait pas déjà sur pouvait chick
les chevaux personnes tout va bien dans
cette grange
[Musique]
c'est cheval et bien figure
fougue
[Musique]
en effet partie qui fait venir sur scène
en espérant qu'elle porte bien son nom
[Musique]
vient de monter à cheval chez nous on
appelle plutôt ça se cramponnait toutes
ses forces tu as eu beaucoup de chance
de ne pas te tuer ne t'approche pas de
cheval va pas c'est pas sa faute je sais
seulement de protéger et servir
ça prend bien ton temps les chevaux
ressource en thons coeur était trop de
libertés tout comme le mien je vais
t'appeler spirit
la troupe brigands il faut qu'on ramène
spirit à sa famille c'est une très
mauvaise idée
je suis partante
je crois en toi le qui tue à la fougue
de ta maman
[Musique]
reste toujours libre mie câline a
partout
j'ai moi confiance
oui
ne pas regarder
[Musique]
ce tuteur avoir trouvé des familles
spirit avec tt de marshmallows pour nous
donner tort
[Musique]
et